udraw studio janvier se trouve sur doom
douze ans après doom 3 voilà c'est mon
anecdote il sort le 13 mai prochain sur
ps4 xbox soit des pc aujourd'hui on a la
chance ensemble de pouvoir faire un
level lazarus
on va se faire plaisir à faire péter du
monstre ok c'est parti je crois que ça
commence nous y sommes déjà tu vas grèce
pas pour histoire samuel hayden s'il te
plaît laisse pas faire la vidéo ça sans
aucune monstre ou c'est le cul show de
monstres là qui vient de se battre les
amis je vous annonce on va totalement
qui fait notre vie puisqu'on a une bonne
panoplie d'armes à on va commencer avec
le bon chaude jeunes audard non non on
va commencer avec la tronçonneuse
voilà on n'a pas le temps à tailler des
brumes être taché peur de tous je verse
100 mais c'est quoi ça c'est au gramme
soit des monstres à ramener vos bande de
bâtards ok c'est parti adacore c'était
prévu ok on y va les gars c'est oh là là
là là c'est parti
l'ultime douar est présent on les
explose on défonce faire sa gueule de
crouch ou à contacter le meilleur à
léopard faire un petit choc violent et
apparemment on peut finir je t'ai
mention laissons-les one shot à atlanta
mais très puissante a levé au finish la
prochaine fois on va passer au super
shotgun au fusil à canon scié
waouh [ __ ] de creamer oh non il est
gros et moche et les croyants qui
converse doux à ça fait rien
attends ya aucune arme qui fait plus mal
que ce à quoi les campagnards chasse le
sanglier avec le fusil à canon scié
question qu'on fasse ça fait mal à votre
petit cul ça allait bien de battre
habituellement faut signer avec secoués
en mêlée de motivation mes salutations
distinguées
ok on les a bien explosé [ __ ] c'était
pendant mitrailleuse elle et moi je veux
tester toutes les armes à d'accord on
passe carrément mode tourelles le bon
câble s'est fait coincer est une
supercherie nous empêchait pour
l'ascenseur on va le tirer par le pied
mais non vas-y hockey passe avant toi
qui tu as à faire
j'ai adoré par là dans le petit conduite
si on fait 300 kg avec que du muscle
mois passés dans un mini coup un horaire
dgh les conduites double c'est pas la
même que nos questions à faire j'ai
lance-roquettes va si bien magro on a
juste eu et ça c'est ma tête elle est
trop fort les [ __ ] h2 finissent aux
pressions nul je peux les justes et tuer
comme ça aux besoins du seco fait des
séquano pour le plaisir
oh là là on a cassé l'omoplate alors la
politique comme celle inverse de tous
les autres fps et possédant tailles tous
tes baisers passionnés sur des montures
qui perdent la vie j'aime rire j'aime
rêver sans toi à toi tu vas être capella
toutefois puisque eu du mal à cinq fois
par jour je peux le père choses comme ça
avec ok ok eh ben on ira la salle avec
toi ok bouge et où vous serez tués
rester en mouvement
voilà c'est ce que je disais vous êtes
tous les monstres oh oui bien pourquoi
paul bien éduqué toi on va vendre cassé
la mâchoire toi ou moi qui est ma tombe
et toi espèce de petite merde c'est un
sketch tu vas vraiment trop à la salle
je sais pourquoi on perd tout le temps
je suis juste content j'ai mis aucun
point de talent vous voyez ce fusil à
pompe
on va en faire un lance roquettes on va
tous améliorés sans même regarder ce que
c'est je m'en bats les couilles
ok les gars je crois qu'on est paré on a
mis tous nos points de talent ça va
faire très très mal
oh le coup le vieux cons qui attendez
quoi aller spécial mâchoire elle
jonathan racine au fait c'est quoi ça
on va te terminé en faisant exploser ton
petit jet pack
l'animateur alors il est où le gros
chien là qui me défonce à chaque fois
celui qui va à la salle ok allez le
petit coup de genou suivant oui la sémec
sauf qu'on fait par an quand on paye dès
qu on va finalement ça soit en rang au
caylar yella yella hiver je termine à la
tucson
il voit la salle en somme c'est quoi toi
et lignon lui allez hop une petite ans
et le petit dernier il est mignon il est
douillet il est david david douillet toi
pas besoin [ __ ] alors lui mais qu'on
va lui réserver la spéciale celle ci a
special au mot dieu à les mecs tu vas
mourir un jour
ces bateaux dans la loi française
devrait jouer à ce jeu à la fin de
chaque journée on vraiment sortir toute
la frustration du corps regardé comme
ses yeux professeur xavier tu ne
m'intéresse pas dans cette situation
alors tu passes la spi comment montre là
où ça la question
et attention ça glisse je crois que j'ai
une bonne réputation légal a plus aucun
monopole - bouclier allait me tuer au
nom on part sur un super show biot et or
[ __ ] t'as je faisais du bluff et ça a
marché apparemment c'est fantastique
est-ce que tout mou qui résiste à ça et
bah non ok ok ok on détermine au bout
qui veut devenir un steak
allez on commence par toi voilà gentil
steak haché ah oui il se prend pour le
captain america du futur doit vraiment
qu'avec tous m'ont crié tu m'énerves est
mort [ __ ] mais je vais trop abusé et
loire injecter une trop grosse descente
leurs dessins
j'ai du mal à dire cette blague voilà ça
me défoule j'ai raté ma blague voyez
exemple parfait de doom ça marche c'est
le peuple qui est un peu un mec bien
sympa se lever ce truc non non
au ixe tél à douelle canada et puis j'ai
jamais fait un harvey 18 fois ça parfois
violents qui fut quoi y'a un déserteur
ici les mecs cayton avons déserté
voilà moi je dormais de grosses suivant
mais plus qu à lui mais c'est un asticot
et s'attaquent à nous tu m'as vraiment
dégagé captain america ce que tu
m'énerves oualata +3 3 buts a fait
oublier ont carrément pour plus qu'avec
son fondement du style ça dégage mais
dont je peux terminer m'exposais on va
retirer un vieux tu es autour d'elles
est décédée coincé en haut tu peux a sa
carte à fait désolé maintenant tu
m'impressionnes plus en fait j'ai vu ton
grand frère je te graver dessus et le
coût de la nuque
c'était une super belle bataille ait ce
que je peux aider à l'ouverture de sept
porteurs du helmand oui
oddo est d'accord ça marche c'est que
débute à djeddah frank chizea schengen
comment ça va en finlande où tu te
demande tout le temps qu'elle suspende
les mythes fracassés mortiers
lance-roquettes alors été pris pour
mario lancer des boules de feu tu
t'arrêtes allez les gars lance roquettes
of la défense on s'est regroupé le coup
c'est tout ce que vous avez dans l'indre
en place d'un bon oeil on va taper
rhinopharyngite s'en aller c'est une
maladie et severino c'est drôle on
n'avait pas vu cela
c'est bon on lui arrache carrément un
morceau de la colonne pour lui mettre
dans la bouche bée âmes et je crois
qu'on arrive à la fin de ce niveau j'ai
pas le droit de vous en montrer plus en
tout cas on s'est bien défoulé j'espère
si vous a plus ces cas n'hésitez pas
voilà mais c'était pas mal a dit oh ça
vous a plu [ __ ] j'avais envie de
continuer de jouer et de tuer tous les
monstres du monde
à l'inversé vous regardez au centre d
une prochaine vidéo moi je retourne
tronçonnés et ben non j'ai plus
d'essence au revoir portez vous bien
jobboom pis
oh